The following content is provided under a
Creative Commons license. Your support will
help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to offer
high quality educational resources for free.
To make a donation or view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: All right. Good morning, everyone.
Let's get started. So we're going to start
6.046 in earnest today. We're going to start
with our first module on divide and conquer.
You've all seen divide and conquer algorithms
before. Merge sort is a classic divide and
conquer algorithm. I'm going to spend just
a couple minutes talking about the paradigm,
give you a slightly more general setting than
merge sort. And then we'll get into two really
cool divide and conquer problems in the sense
that these are problems for which divide and
conquer works very well-- mainly, convex hall
and median finding.
So before I get started on the material, let
me remind you that you should be signing up
for a recitation section on Stellar. And please
do that even if you don't plan on attending
sections. Because we need that so we can assign
your problem sets to be graded, OK?
So that's our way of partitioning problem
sets as well. And then the other thing is
problem set one is going to go out today.
And that it's a one week problem set.
All problem sets are going to be a week in
duration. Please read these problem sets the
day that they come out. Spend 5, 10 minutes
reading them.
Some things are going to look like they're
magic, that they're-- how could I possibly
prove this? If you think about it for a bit,
it'll become obvious. We promise you that.
But get started early. Don't get started at
7:00 PM when we have 11:59 PM deadline on
Thursday, all right? That four hours or five
hours of time may not be enough to go from
magical to obvious, OK?
So let's get started with the paradigm associated
with divide and conquer. It's just a beautiful
notion that you can break up the problem into
smaller parts and somehow compose the solutions
to the smaller parts. And of course, the details
are going to be what's important when we take
a particular problem instance.
But let's say we're given a problem of size
n. We're going to divide it into a sub problems--
I'll put that in quotes so you know it's a
symbol-- a sub problems of size n over b.
And here, a is an integer.
And a is going to be greater than or equal
to 1. It could be two. It could be three.
It could be four.
This is the generalization I alluded to. And
b does not have to be two or even an integer.
But it has to be strictly greater than one.
Otherwise, there's no notion of divide and
conquer. You're not breaking things up into
smaller problems. So b should be strictly
greater than one. So that's the general setting.
And then you'll solve each sub problem recursively.
And the idea here is that once the sub problems
become really small, they become constant
size, it's relatively easy to solve them.
You can just do exhaustive search.
If you have 10 elements and you're doing effectively
a cubic search, well, 10 cubed is 1,000. That's
a constant. You're in great shape as long
as the constants are small enough.
And so you're going to recurse until these
problems get small. And then typically-- this
is not true for all divide and conquer approaches.
But for most of them, and certainly the ones
we're going to cover today, the smarts is
going to be in the combination step-- when
you combine these problems, the solutions
of these sub problems, into the overall solution.
And so that's the story.
Typically, what happens in terms of efficiency
is that you can write a recurrence that's
associated with this divide and conquer algorithm.
And you say t of n, which is a running time,
for a problem of size n is going to be a times
tfn over b-- and this is a recurrence-- plus
the work that you need to do for the merge
operational or the combine. This is the same
as merge.
And so you get a recurrence. And you're not
quite done yet in terms of the analysis. Because
once you have the recurrence, you do have
to solve the recurrence. And it's usually
not that hard and certainly it's not going
to be particularly difficult for the divide
and conquer examples that we're going to look,
at least today.
But we also have this theorem that's called
the master theorem that is essentially something
where you can fairly mechanically plug in
the a's and the b's and whatever you have
there-- maybe it's theta n, maybe it's theta
n square-- and get the solution to the recurrence.
I'm actually not going to do that today. But
you'll hear once again about the massive theorem
tomorrow in section. And it's a fairly straightforward
template that you can use for most of the
divide and conquer examples we're going to
look at in 046 with one exception that we'll
look at in median finding today that will
simply give you the solution to the recurrence,
OK?
So you've see most of these things before.
That's a little bit of setup. And so let's
dive right in into convex hull, which is my
favorite problem when it comes to using divide
and conquer.
So convex hull, I got a little prop here which
will save me from writing on the board and
hopefully be more understandable. But the
idea here is that in this case, we have a
two dimensional problem with a bunch of points
in a two dimensional plane. You can certainly
do convex hull for three dimensions, many
dimensions. And convexity is something that
is a fundamental notion in optimization.
And maybe we'll get to that in 6046 in advanced
topics, maybe not. But in the context of today's
lecture, what we're interested in doing is
essentially finding an envelope or a hull
associated with a collection of points on
a two dimensional plane. And this hull obviously
is going to be something, as you can guess,
that encloses all of these points, OK?
So what I have here, if I make this string
taut enough-- this is not working so well,
but I think you get the picture. All right,
so that's not a convex hull. This is not a
convex hull for the reason that I have a bunch
of points outside of the hull.
All right, so let me just-- that is a convex
hull. And now if I start stretching like that
or like this or like that, that's still a
convex hull, OK? So that's the game.
We have to find an algorithm. And we look
at a couple of different ones that will find
all of these segments that are associated
with this convex hull, OK? So this is a segment
that's part of the convex hull.
That's a segment that's part of the convex
hull. If, in fact, I had something like this--
and this was stretched out-- because I have
those two points outside the convex hull,
this may still be a segment that's part of
the electronics hall but this one is not,
right? So that's-- the game here is to find
these segments. So if you're going to working
with segments or tangents-- they're going
to be used synonymously-- all of the tangents
or segments associated with the entirety of
the convex hull and we have to discover them.
And only input that we have is the set of
pointx-- xiy coordinates.
And there's just a variety of algorithms that
you can use to do this. The one that I wish
I had time to explain but I'll just mention
is what's called a gift wrapping algorithm.
You might not have done this, but I guarantee
you I said you probably have taken a misshapen
gift, right, and tried to wrap it in gift
wrapping paper.
And when you're doing that, you're essentially--
if you're doing it right you're essentially
trying to find the convex hull of this three
dimensional structure. You're trying to tighten
it up. You're trying to find the minimum amount
of gift wrapping paper.
I'm not sure if you've ever thought about
minimizing gift wrapping paper, but you should
have. And that's the convex hull of this three
dimensional shape. But we'll stick to two
dimensions because we'll have to draw things
on the board. So let me just spec this out
a bit.
I've been given endpoints in a plane. And
those set of points are s, xi, yi such that
i equals 1, 2 to n. And we're just going to
assume here, just to make things easy because
we don't want to have segments that are null
or segments that are a little bit different
because they're discontinuous. But we're going
to assume that no two have the same x-coordinate.
This is just a matter of convenience. And
no two have the same y-coordinate.
And then finally, no three in a line.
Because we want to be able to look at pairs
of points and find these segments. And it
just gets kind of inconvenient. You have to
do special cases if there of them are on a
line. And so the convex hull itself is the
smallest polygon containing all points in
s. And we're going to call that ch of s--
convex hull of s.
STUDENT: Smallest convex polygon.
PROFESSOR: The smallest convex polygon--
thank you. And so just as an example on the
board, when you have something like this,
you're going to have your convex hull being
that. This one is inside of it.
These two points are inside of it. And all
the other ones form the hull. And so we might
have p, q, r, s, t, u. And v and x are inside
of the hull. They're not part of the specification
of ch of s, which I haven't quite told you
how we're going to specify that.
But the way you're going to specify that is
simply by representing it as a sequence of
points that are on the boundary on the hull
in clockwise order. And you can think of this
as being a doubly linked list in terms of
the data structure that you'd use if you coded
this up. So in this case, it would be p to
q to r to s.
You're going to start with t in this case.
It's a doubly linked list. So you could conceivably
start with anything. But that's the representation
of the convex hull.
And we're going to use clockwise just because
we want to be clear on as to what order we're
enumerating these points. It's going to become
important when we do the divide and conquer
algorithm. So let's say that we didn't care
about divide and conquer just for the heck
of it and I gave you a bunch of points over
here.
Can you think of a simple-- forget efficiency
for just a couple of minutes. Can you think
of a simple algorithm that would generate
the segments of the convex hull? For example,
I do not want to generate this segment vx.
If I think of a segment as being something
that is defined by two points, then I don't
want to generate the segment vx because clearly
the segment is not part of the convex hull.
But whereas the segment pq, qr, rs, et cetera,
they're all part of the convex hull, right?
So what is the obvious brute force algorithm,
forgetting efficiency, that given this set
of points will generate one by one the segments
of the convex hull?
Anybody? Did you have your head up? No? Go
ahead. Yep.
STUDENT: Draw the line and check how many other lines intersect with it.
PROFESSOR: Draw the line and check how many
lines it intersects with.
STUDENT: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: Is there-- I think you got-- you
draw the line. That's good, right?
STUDENT: [LAUGHS]
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHING]
PROFESSOR: Well-- but you want to do a little
more. Yeah, go ahead.
STUDENT: For every pair of points you see, make a half-plane and see where they complete
all of their other points. [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Ah, so that's good. That's good.
That's good.
All right, so the first person who breaks
the ice here always gets a Frisbee. Sorry
man. At least I only hit the lecturer-- no
liability considerations here. OK, now I'm
getting scared.
Right, so I think there's a certain amount
of when I throw this, am I going to choke
or not, right? But it's going to get higher
when one of you guys in the back answers a
question. So you're exactly right.
And you draw a line. And then you just look
at it. And you look at the half plane.
And if all the points are to one side, it
is a segment of the convex hull. If they're
not, it's not a segment-- beautiful. All right,
are we done? Can we go and enjoy the good
weather outside?
No, we've got ways to go here. So this is
not the segment whereas one-- let me draw
that. I should draw these in a dotted way.
This is not a segment. This is not a segment.
This is a segment.
And I violated my rule of these three not
being in a straight line. So I'll move this
over here. And then that's a segment and so
on and so forth, OK? Right?
STUDENT: It's no longer a side with the ones below it.
PROFESSOR: I'm sorry?
STUDENT: It would have to go directly to the bottom one from the left one.
PROFESSOR: Oh, you're right. That's a good
point. That's an excellent point.
SO what happened here was when I moved that
out-- exactly right. Thank you. This is good.
So when I moved this out here, what happened
was-- and I drew this-- well, this one here,
my convex hull, changed. The problem specification
changed on me. It was my fault. But then what
would happen, of course, is as I move this,
that would become the segment that was part
of the convex hull, OK?
So sorry to confuse people. But what we have
here in terms of an algorithm, if I leave
the points the same, works perfectly well.
So let me just leave the points the same and
just quickly recap, which is, I'm going to
take a pair of points.
And I'm going to draw-- and let me just draw
this in a dotted fashion first. And I'm going
to say that's the segment. And I'm going to
take a look at that line and say this breaks
up the plane into two half planes. Are all
about points on one side?
And if the answer is yes, I'm going to go
ahead and, boom, say that is a segment of
my convex hull. If the answers is no, like
in this case, I'm going to drop that segment,
OK? So now let's talk about complexity.
Let's say that there are n points here. And
how many segments do I have? I have O n square
theta n square segments.
And what is the complexity of the test? What
is the complexity of the test that's associated
with, once I've drawn the segments, deciding
whether the segment is going to be a tangent
which is part of the convex hull or not? What
is the complexity?
STUDENT: O n.
PROFESSOR: O n-- exactly right. So on test
complexity-- and so we got over theta n cubed
complexity, OK? So it makes sense to do divide
and conquer if you can do better than this.
Because this is a really simple algorithm.
The good news is we will be able to do better
than that. And now that we have a particular
algorithm-- I'm not quite ready to show you
that yet.
Now that we have a particular algorithm, we
can think about how we can improve things.
And of course we're going to use divide and
conquer. So let's go ahead and do that. And
so generally, the divide and conquer, as I
mentioned before, in most cases, the division
is pretty straightforward.
And that's the case here as well. All the
fun is going to be in the merge step. Right,
so what we're going to do, as you can imagine,
is we're going to take these points.
And we're going to break them up. And the
way we're going to break them up is by dividing
them into half lengths. We're going to just
draw a line.
And we're going to say everything to the left
of the line is one sub problem, everything
to the right of the line is another sub problem,
go off and find the convex hull for each of
the sub problems. If you have two points,
you're done, obviously. It's trivial.
And at some point, you can say I'm just going
to deal with brute force. If we can go down
to order n cubed, if n is small, I can just
apply that algorithm. So it doesn't even have
to be the base case of n equals 1 or n equals
2. That's a perfectly fine thing to do.
But you could certainly go with n equals 10,
as I mentioned before, and run this brute
force algorithm. And so at that point, you
know that you can get down to small enough
size sub problems for which you can find the
convex hull efficiently. And then you've got
these two convex hulls which are clearly on
two different half planes because that's the
way you defined them.
And now you've got to merge them. And that's
where all the fun is, OK? So let's just write
this out again.
You're going to sort the points by x-coordinates.
And we're going to do this once and for all.
We don't have to keep sorting here because
we're just going to be partitioning based
on x-coordinates.
And we can keep splitting based on x-coordinates
because we want to generate these half-lengths,
right? So if we can do those once and for
all-- and for the input set S, we're going
to divide into the left half A and right half
B by the x-coordinates. And then we're going
to compute CH of A and CH of B recursively.
And then we're going to combine. So the only
difference here from what we had before is
the specification of the division. It looked
pretty generic.
It's similar to the paradigm that I wrote
before. But I've specified exactly how I'm
going to break this up. So let's start with
the merge operation. We're going to spend
most of our time specing that.
And again, there's many ways you could do
the merge. And we want the most efficient
way. That's obviously going to determine complexity.
So, big question-- how to merge.
So what I have here, if I look at the merge
step, is I've created my two sub problems
corresponding to these two half planes. And
what I have here is-- let's say I've generated,
at this point, a convex hull associated with
each of these sub problems. So what I have
here is a1, a2.
I'm going to go clockwise to specify the convex
hull. And the other thing that I'm going to
do is in the sub problem case, my starting
point is going to be for the left sub problem,
the coordinate that has the highest x value,
OK? So that's a1 in this case-- the highest
x value going over. x is increasing to the
right.
And for the right half of the problem, it's
going to be the coordinate that has the lowest
x value. And I'm going to go clockwise in
both of these cases. So when you see an ordering
associated with the subscripts for these points,
start with a1 or b1 and then go clockwise.
And that's how we number this-- so just notational,
nothing profound here.
So I got these two convex hulls-- these sub
hulls, if you will. And what I need to do
now is merge them together. And you can obviously
look at this and it's kind of obvious what
the overall convex hull is, right?
But the key thing is, I'm going to have to
look at each of the pairs of points that are
associated with this and that and try to generate
the tangents, the new tangents, that are not
part of the sub hulls, but they're part of
the overall hull, right? So in this case,
you can imagine an algorithm that is going
to kind of do what this brute force algorithm
does except that it's looking at a point from
here and a point from here.
So you could imagine that I'm going to do
a pairwise generation of segments. And then
I'm going to check to see whether these segments
are actually tangents that are part of the
overall convex hull or not. So what I would
do here is I'd look at this.
And is that going to be part of the overall
hull? No, and precisely why not? Someone tell
me why this segment a1 b1 is not part of the
overall hull? Yeah, go ahead.
STUDENT: If we were to draw a line through the whole thing there would be one on both sides.
PROFESSOR: Exactly right-- that's exactly
right. So here you go. So that's not part
of it. Now, if I look at this-- well, same
reason that's not part of it.
In this case-- and this is a fairly obvious
example. I'm going to do something that's
slightly less obvious in case you get your
hopes up that we have this trivial algorithm,
OK? This is looking good, right? That's supposed
to be a straight line, by the way.
So a4 b2-- I mean, that's looking good, right?
Because all the points are on one side. So
a4 b2 is our upper tangent. Right, so our
upper tangent is something that we're going
to define as-- if I look at each of these
things, I'm going to say they have a yij.
OK, what is yij? yij is the y-coordinate.
of the segment that I'm looking at, the ij
segment.
So this yij is for ai and bj. So what I have
here is y42 out here. And this is-- for the
upper tangent, yij is going to be maximum,
right? Because that's essentially something
which would ensure me that there are no points
higher than that, right?
So if I go up all the way and I find this
that has the maximum yij, that is going to
be my upper tangent. Because only for that
will I have no points ahead of that, OK? So
yij is upper tangent.
This is going to be maximum. And I'm not going
to write this down, but it makes sense that
the lower tangent is going to have the lowest
yij. Are we all good here? Yeah, question.
STUDENT: So I am just wondering, I couldn't hear
what she said why we moved out a1 b1.
PROFESSOR: OK, so good. Let me-- that reason
we moved out a1 b1 is because if I just drew
a1 b1 like this-- and I'm extrapolating this.
This is again supposed to be a straight line.
Then you clearly see that there are points
on either side of the a1 b1 segment when you
look at the overall problem, correct? You
see that on a1 b1, b2 is on this side, b3
is on this side if I just extend this line
all the way to infinity in both directions.
And that violates the requirement that the
segment be part of the overall hull, OK?
That make sense? Good. So, everybody with
me?
So clearly, there's a trivial merge algorithm
here. And the trivial merge algorithm is to
look at not every pair of points-- every ab
pair, right? Every aibj pair.
And so what is the complexity of doing that?
If I have n total points, the complexity would
be-- would be in square, right? Because maybe
I'd have half here and half here, ignore constants.
And you could say, well, it's going to be
n squared divided by 4, but that's theta n
squared. So there's an obvious merge algorithm
that is theta n square looking at all pairs
of points. And when I mean all pairs of points,
I mean like an a and a b.
Because I want to pick a pair when I go left
of that dividing line and then right of the
dividing line. But either way, it's theta
n square, OK? So now you look at that and
you go, huh. Can I do a better?
What if I just went for the highest a point
and the highest b point and I just, no, that's
it? I'm done-- constant time. Wouldn't that
be wonderful? Yeah, wonderful, but incorrect,
OK?
Right, so what is an example. And so
this is something that I spent a little bit
of time last night concocting. So I'm like
you guys too. I do my problem set the night
before.
Well, don't do as I do. Do as I say. But I've
done this before. So that's the difference.
But this particular example is new. So what
I have here is I'm going to show you why there's
not a trivial algorithm, OK, that-- I got
to get these angles right-- that you can't
just pick the highest points and keep going,
right?
And then that would be constant time. So that's
my a over here. And let's assume that I have
my dividing line like that. And then what
I'm going to do here-- and I hope I get this
right-- is I'm going to have something like
this, like that.
And then I'm going to have b1 here clockwise--
so b2, b3, and b4. So as you can see here,
if I look at a4-- a little adjustment necessary.
OK, so if I look at that, a4 to b1 versus--
I mean, just eyeball it.
A3 to b1-- right, is a4 to b1 going to be
the upper tangent? No, right? So now a3 is
lower than a4. You guys see that?
And b1 is lower than b2, right? So it's clear
that if I just took a4 to b2 that it will
not be an upper tangent. Everybody see that?
Yep, all right, good. So we can't have a constant
time algorithm. We have theta and square in
the back. So it is there something-- maybe
theta n?
How would we do this merge and find the upper
tangent by being a little smarter about searching
for pairs of points that give us this maximum
yij? I mean, the goal here is simple. At some
level, if you looked at the brute force, I
would generate each of these things.
I would find the yj intercepts associated
with this line. And I just pick the maximum.
And the constant time algorithm doesn't work.
The theta n squared algorithm definitely works.
But we don't like it. So there has to be something
in between. So, any ideas? Yeah, back there.
STUDENT: So... I had a question. [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: No, you're just finding-- no, you're
maximizing the yij. So for once you have this
segment-- so the question was, isn't the obvious
merge algorithm theta n cubed, right? And
my answer is no, because the theta n extra
factor came from the fact that you had to
check every point, every endpoint, to see
on which side of the plane it was. Whereas
here, what I'm doing is I've got this one
line here that is basically y equals 0, if
you like, or y equals some-- I'm sorry, x
equals 0 or x equals some value.
And I just need to, once I have the equation
for the line associated with a4 b1 or a4 b2,
I just have to find the intercept of it, which
is constant time, right? And then once I find
the intercept of it, I just maximize that
intercept to get my yij. So I'm good, OK?
So it's only theta n squared, right? Good
question. So this is actually quite-- very,
very, very clever.
This particular algorithm is called the two
finger algorithm. And I do have multiple fingers,
but it's going to work a lot better if I borrow
Eric's finger. And we're going to demonstrate
to you the two finger algorithm for merging
these two convex hulls. And then we'll talk
about the complexity of it.
And my innovation again last night was to
turn this from a two-finger algorithm. Not
only did I have the bright idea of using Eric--
I decided it was going to become the two finger
an string algorithm. So this is wild.
This is my contribution to 046 lore-- come
on. So the way the two finger algorithm works--
this pseudo code should be incomprehensible.
If you just look at it and you go, what, right?
But this demo is going to clear everything
up. Right so here's what you do. So now we're
going to do a demo of the merge algorithm
that is a clever merge algorithm than the
one that uses order n square time. And it's
correct. It's going to get you the correct
upper tangent and what we are starting at
here is with Erik’s left finger on A1, which
is defined to be the point that's closest
to the vertical line that you see here, the
one that has the highest x-coordinate. And
my finger is on B1, which is the point that
has the smallest X-coordinate on the right
hand side sub-hull. And what we do is we compute,
for the segment A1 B1, we compute by Yij,
in this case Y11, which is the intercept on
the vertical line that you see here that Erik
just marked with a red dot. And you can look
at the pseudocode over on, to my right if
I face the board. And what happens now is
I'm going to move clockwise, and I'm going
to go from B1 to B4. And what happened here?
Did the Yij increase or decrease? Well, as
you can see it decreased. And so I'm going
to go back to B1. And we're not quite done
with this step here. Erik’s going to go
counterclockwise over to A4. And we're going
to check again, yeah, keep the string taught,
check again whether Yij increased or decreased
and as is clear from here Yij increased. So
now we move to this point. And as of this
moment we think that A4 B1 has the highest
Yij. But we have a while loop. We’re going
to have to continue with this while loop,
and now what happens is, I’m going to go
from B1 clockwise again to B4. And when this
happens, did Yij increase or decrease? Well
it decreased. So I'm going to go back to B1
and Erik now is going to go counterclockwise
to A3. And as you can see Y31 increased a
little bit, so we're going to now stop this
iteration of the algorithm and we're at A3
B1, which we think at this point is our upper
tangent, but let's check that. Start over
again on my side B1 to B4, what happened?
Well Yij decreased. So I'm going to go back
to B1. And then Erik’s going to try. He’s
going conterclockwise, he's going to go A3
to A2 and, well, big decrease in Yij. Now
Erik goes back to A3. At this point we've
tried both moves, my clockwise move and Erik’s
counterclockwise move. My move from B1 to
B4 and Erik’s move from A3 to A2. So we've
converged, we're out of the while loop, A3
B1 for this example is our upper tangent.
All right. You can have your finger back Erik.
So the reason this works is because we have
a convex hull here and a convex hull here.
We are starting with the points that are closest
to each other in terms of A1 being the closest
to this vertical line, B1 being the closest
to this vertical line, and we are moving upward
in both directions because I went clockwise
and Erik went counterclockwise. And that's
the intuition of why this algorithm works.
We're not going to do a formal proof of this
algorithm, but the monotonicity property corresponding
to the convexity of this subhull and the convexity
of the subhull essentially can give you a
formal proof of correctness of this algorithm,
but as I said we won't cover that in 046.
So all that remains now is to look at our
pseudocode which matches the execution that
you just saw and talk about the complexity
of the pseudocode.
So what is the complexity of this algorithm?
It's order n, right? So what has happening
here, if you look at this while loop, is that
while I have two counters, I'm essentially
looking at two operations per loop.
And either one of those counters is guaranteed
to increment through the loop. And so since
I have in this case p points, in one case
p plus q equals n-- so let's say I had p points
here and I have q points here. And got p plus
q equals n.
And I got a theta n merge simply because I'm
going to be running through and incrementing--
as long as I'm in the loop, I'm going to be
incrementing either the i or the j. And the
maximum they can go to are p and q before
I bounce out of the loop or before they rotate
around.
And so that's why this is theta n. And so
you put it all together in terms of what the
merge corresponds to in terms of complexity
and put that together with the overall divide
and conquer. We have a case where this is
looking like a recurrence that you've seen
many a time t of n.
I've broken it up into two sub problems. So
I have 2. And I could certainly choose this
l over here that's my line l to be such that
I have a good partition between the two sets
of points.
Now, if I choose l to be all the way on the
right hand side, then I have this large sub
problem-- makes no sense whatsoever. So what
I can do-- there's nothing that's stopping
me when I've sorted these points by the x-coordinates
to do the division such that there's exactly
the same number, assuming an even number of
points n, exactly the same number on the left
hand side or the right hand side. But I can
get that right roughly certainly within one
very easily.
So that's where the n over 2 comes from, OK?
In the next problem that we'll look at, the
median finding problem, we'll find that trying
to get the sub problems to be of roughly equal
size is actually a little difficult, OK? But
I want to point out that in this particular
case, it's easy to get sub problems that are
half the size because you've done the sorting.
And then you just choose the line, the vertical
line such that you've got a bunch of points
that are on either side. And then in terms
of the merge operation, we have 2t n over
2 plus theta n. People recognize this recurrence?
It's the old merge sort recurrence.
So we did all of this in-- well, it's not
merge sort. Clearly the algorithm is not merge
sort. We got the same recurrence.
And so this is theta n log n-- so a lot better
than theta nq. And there's no convex hull
algorithm that's in the general case better
than this. Even the gift wrapping algorithm
that I mentioned to you, with the right data
structures, it gets down to that in terms
of theta n log n, but no better.
OK, so good. That's pretty much what I had
here. Again, like I said, happy to answer
questions about the correctness of this loop
algorithm for merge later. Any other questions
associated with this?
STUDENT: Question.
Yeah, back there.
STUDENT: If the input is recorded by x coordinates, can you do better than [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: No, you can't, because-- I mean,
the n log n for the pre-sorting, I mean, there's
another theta n log n for the sorting at the
top level. And we didn't actually use that,
right? So the question was, can we do better
if the input was pre sorted?
And I actually did not even use the complexity
of the sort. We just matched it in this case.
So theta n log n-- and then you can imagine
maybe that you could do a theta n sort if
these points were small enough and you rounded
them up and you could use a bucket sort or
a counting sort and lower that.
So this theta n log n is kind of fundamental
to the divide and conquer algorithm. The only
way you can improve that is by making a merge
process that's even faster. And we obviously
tried to cook up a theta one merge process.
But that didn't work out, OK?
STUDENT: But are there algorithms that [INAUDIBLE] ?
PROFESSOR: First-- if you assume certain things
about the input, you're absolutely, right?
So one thing you'll discover in algorithms
in 6046 as well is that we're never satisfied.
OK, so I just said, oh, you can't do better
than theta n log n.
But that's in the general case. And I think
I mentioned that. You're on the right track.
If the input is pre sorted, you can take that
away-- no, it doesn't help in that particular
instance if you have general settings. But
if you-- the two dimensional case-- if the
hull, all the segments have a certain characteristic--
not quite planar, but something that's a little
more stringent than that-- you could imagine
that you can do improvements. I don't know
if any compelling special case input for convex
hull from which you can do better than theta
n log n.
But that's a fine exercise for you, which
is in what cases, given some structure on
the points, can I do better than theta n log
n? So that's something that keeps coming up
in the algorithm literature, if you can use
that, OK? Yeah, back there-- question.
STUDENT: Where's your [INAUDIBLE] step?
You also have to figure out which lines to remove from each of your two...
PROFESSOR: Ah, good point. And you're exactly,
absolutely right. And I just realized that
I skipped that step, right?
Thank you so much. So the question was, how
do I remove the lines? And it's actually fairly
straightforward.
Let's keep this up here. And we don't need
this incomprehensible pseudo code, right?
So let's erase that.
And thank you for asking that question. So
it's a little simple cut and paste approach
where let's say that I find the upper tangent
ai bj. And I find the lower tangent.
Let's call it ak bm. And in this particular
instance, what do I have? I have a1, a2, a3,
a4 as being one of my sub hulls. And then
I have b1, b2, b3, b4 as the other one.
Now, what did we determine to be the upper
tangent? Was it a3 b1? Right, a3 b1?
So a3 b1 was my upper tangent. And I guess
it was a1-- a1 b4? A1 b4 was my lower tangent.
So the big question is, now that I've found
these two, how do I generate the collect representation
of the overall convex hull? And so it turns
out that you have to do this-- and then the
complexity of this is important as well. And
you need to do what's called a cut and paste
that's associated with this where we're going
to just look at this and that.
So if we're going to have these two things,
then we've got to generate a list of points.
Now, clearly a4 is not going to be part of
that, right? A4 is not going to be part of
the overall hull.
What is it that we want? We want something
like a1, a2, a3, b1, b2, b3, b4, right? But
there's a point that we have to discard here.
Agree?
And so the way we do this is very mechanical.
That's the good news here. I mean, you don't
have to look at it pictorially.
I just made that up looking at-- eyeballing
it. Clearly, a computer doesn't have eyeballs,
right? And so what we're going to do is we're
going to say the first link-- in general,
the first link is ai to bj.
Because that's my upper tangent, OK? And in
this case, it's going to be a3 d1, OK? And
then I'm going to go down the b list until
you see bm, which is the lower tangent.
You're on the b list. So you're looking for
the lower tangent point. And then you're going
to jump until you see bm. You link it to ak,
OK?
You link it to ak and continue until you return
to ai. And then you have your circular
list, OK? So what you see here is you have
a3 here. So I'm going to go ahead and write
out the execution of what I just wrote here.
So I have a3. And I'm going to go jump over
to b1. So I'm going to write down b1. Then
I'm going to along the b's until I get to
b4.
In this case, I'm going to include all of
the b's. So I got b1, b2, b3, b4. And then
I'm going to jump from b4 to a1 because that's
part of my lower tangent.
And I got a1 here, a2. And then I'm back to
a3, which is great. Because then I'm done,
OK?
And so exactly what I said happened, thank
goodness, which is we dropped a4 but we kept
all the other points. Does that answer your
question? Good.
What is the complexity of cut and paste? It's
order n. I'm just walking through these lists.
So there's no hidden complexity here, OK?
Good, good-- thank you. You definitely deserve
a Frisbee.
In fact, you deserve two, right? Where are
you? I-- oh, could you stand up?
Yeah, right-- two colors. All right. Oh, so
he-- well, you can give it to him if you like.
So good, thank you.
So are we done? Are we done with convex hull?
OK, good. So let's go on and do median finding.
Very different-- very different set of issues
here.
Still on divide and conquer, but a very different
set of issues. The specification here is,
of course, straightforward. You can think
of it as I just want a better algorithm than
sorting and looking for the median at the
particular position-- in over two position,
for example. Let's say n is odd. And it's
floor of n over 2. You can find that median.
Right, so it's pretty easy if you can do sorting.
But we're never satisfied with using a standard
algorithm. If we think that we can do better
than that. So the whole game here is going
to be I'm going to find the median.
And I want to do it in better than theta n
log n time. OK, so that's what median finding
is all about. You're going to use divide and
conquer for this.
And so in general, we're going to define,
given a set of n numbers, define rank of x
as the numbers in the set that are greater
than-- I'm sorry, less than or equal to x.
I mean, you could have defined it differently.
We're going to go with less than or equal
to.
So in general, the rank, of course, is something
that could be used very easily to find the
median. So if you want to find the element
of rank n plus 1 divided by 2 floor, that's
what we call the lower median. And n plus
1 divided by 2 ceiling is the upper median.
And they may be the same if n is odd.
But that's what we want. So you can think
of it as it's not median finding, but finding
elements with a certain rank. And we want
to do this in linear time, OK?
So we're going to apply divide and conquer
here. And as always, the template can be instantiated.
And the devil is in the details of either
division or merge.
And we had most of our fun with convex hull
on the merge operation. It turns out most
of the fun here with respect to median finding
is in the divide, OK? So what I want is the
definition of a select routine that takes
a set of numbers s.
And this is the rank. So I want a rank i.
And that i might be n over 2-- well, floor
of n plus 1 over 2, whatever?
And so what does the divide and conquer look
like? Well, the first thing you need to do
is divide. And as of now, we're just going
to say you're going to pick some element x
belonging to s.
And this choice is going to be crucial. But
at this point, I'm not ready to specify this
choice yet, OK? So we're going to have to
do this cleverly. And then what we're going
to do is we're going to compute on k, which
is the rank of x, and generate two sub arrays
such that I want to find the fifth highest
element. I want to find the median element.
I want to find the 10th highest element. So
I have to keep track of what happens in the
sub problems. Because the sub problems are
going to determine, depending on how many
elements are inside those sub problems, which
I can only determine after I've solved those
sub problems. I'm going to have to collect
that information and put it together in the
merge operation.
So if I want to find the 10th highest element
and I've broken it up relatively arbitrarily,
it's quite possible that the 10th highest
element is going to be discovered in the left
one or the right one. And I have to show that
it's the 10th highest. And it might be that
there's four elements in the left and five
on the right that are-- let's see.
If I defined the rank as less than or equal
to x, there's four on the left and five on
the right that are smaller. And that's why
this is the 10th highest element. And that's
essentially what we have to look at. So b
and c are going to correspond to the sub arrays
that you can clearly eliminate one of them.
You can count the number of elements in b,
count the number of elements in c. And you
can eliminate one of them in this recursion
as you're discovering this element with the
correct rank-- in this case, i. So let me
write the rest of this out and make sure we're
all on the same page.
What I have here pictorially is I've generated
b here and c. So this is all of b and that's
all of c. I have k minus 1 elements here in
b.
And let's say I have n minus k elements in
c. And I'm going to do-- essentially take--
once I've selected a particular element, I'm
going to look at all of the elements that
are less than it and put it into the array
b. I'm going to look at all the elements that
are better than it.
Let's assume all elements are unique. I'm
going to put all of them into c. And I'm going
to recur on b and c. Those two are my sub
problems.
But what I have to do is once I recur and
I discover the ranks of the sub problems,
I have to put them together. So what I have
here is if k equals i-- so I computed the
rank and I realized that if k equals-- equals
i, I should say-- if k equals i, then I'm
going to just return x. I'm done at this point.
I got lucky. I picked an element x and it
magically ended up having the correct rank,
OK? Not always going to happen. And so in
other case, if k is greater than i, then going
to return select bi.
So what I've done here is if k is greater
than i, then I'm going to say, oh, so now
I'm going to have to find the element in b.
I know that it's going to be in b because
k is greater than i. And I've got to find
the exact position depending on what i is
over here. But it's going to be somewhere
between 1 and k minus 1.
And then the last case is if k is less than
i, then this is a little more tricky. I'm
going to turn on c of i minus k, OK? So what
happens here is that my k is-- the rank for
the x that I looked at over here is less than
i.
So I know that I'm going to find this element
that I'm looking for in c. But if I just look
at c, I don't want to look at c and look for
an element of rank i within c, right? That
doesn't make sense because I'm looking for
an element of rank i in the overall array
that was given to me.
So I have to subtract out the k elements that
correspond to x and all of the k minus 1 elements
that are in b to go figure out exactly what
position or rank I'm looking for in the sub
array corresponding to c, OK? So, people buy
that. So that's just a small, little thing
that you have to keep in mind as you do this.
So that's pretty straightforward, looking
pretty good. And you say, well, am I done
here? And as you can imagine, the answer is
no, because we haven't specified this value.
Now, can someone tell me, at least from an
efficiency standpoint, what might happen,
what we're looking for here? As you can imagine,
we want to improve on theta n log n. And so
you could you say, well, I'm happy with theta
n. That theta n complexity algorithm is better
than a theta n log n complexity algorithm,
which is kind of in the bag.
Because we know how to sort and we know how
to index. So we want a theta n algorithm.
Now, if you take this and if I just picked,
let's say, the biggest element-- I kept picking
x to be n or n minus 1 or just picked a constant
value. I picked x to be in the middle.
I picked the index. I can always pick an element
based on its index. I can always go for the
middle one.
So what is the worst case complexity of this
algorithm? If I don't specify or I give you
this arbitrary selection corresponding to
x belonging to s, what is the worst case complexity
of this algorithm? Yeah, go ahead.
STUDENT: N squared.
PROFESSOR: N squared-- why is that?
STUDENT: Because if you [INAUDIBLE] take like the least element.
PROFESSOR: Yep.
STUDENT: How do you compare like N o against the other analysis?
PROFESSOR: Exactly right. That's exactly right.
So what happens is that you're doing a bunch
of work here with this theta n work.
Right here, this is theta n work, OK? So given
that you're doing theta n work here, you have
to be really careful as to how you pick the
x element. So what might happen is that you
end up picking the x over here.
And given the particular rank you're looking
for, you have to now-- you're left with a
large array that has n minus 1 elements in
the worst case. You started with n. You did
not go to n over 2 and n over 2, which is
what divide and conquer is all about-- even
n over b, OK?
You went to n minus 1. And then you go to
n minus 2. And you go to n minus 3 because
you're constantly picking-- this is worst
case analysis. You're constantly picking these
sub arrays to be extremely unbalanced.
So when the sub arrays are extremely unbalanced,
you end up doing theta n work in each
level of the recursion. And those theta n's,
because you're going down all the way from
n to one, are going to be theta n square when
you keep doing that, OK? So thanks for that
analysis.
And so this is theta n squared if you have
a batch selection. So we won't talk about
randomized algorithms, but the problem with
randomized algorithms is that the analysis
will be given a probability distribution.
And it'll be expected time.
What we want here is a deterministic algorithm
that is guaranteed to run in worst case theta
n. So we want a deterministic way of picking
x belonging to s such that all of this works
out and when we get our recurrence and we
solve it, somehow magically we're getting
fully balanced partitions-- firmly balanced
sub problems in the sense that it's not n
minus 1 and 1. It's something like-- it could
even be n over 10 and 9n over 10.
But as long as you guarantee that, you're
shaking things down geometrically. And the
asymptotics is going to work out. but the
determinism is what we need.
And so we're going to pick x cleverly. And
we don't want the rank x to be extreme.
So this is not the only way you could do it,
but this is really very clever.
There's a deterministic way. And you're going
to see some arbitrary constants here. And
we'll talk about them once I've described
it. But what we're going to do is we're going
to arrange s into columns of size 5, right?
We're going to take this single array. And
we're going to make it a two dimensional array
where the number of rows is five and the number
of columns that you have is n over 5-- the
ceiling in this case. And then we're going
to sort it each column, big elements on top.
And we're going to do this in linear time.
And you might say, how did that happen? Well,
there's only five elements. So it's linear.
You could do whatever you wanted. You could
do n raised to four.
But it's five raised to four and it's constants.
Don't you love theory? So then we're going
to find what we're going to call the median
of medians.
So I'm going to explain this. This works for
arbitrary rank, but it's a little easier to
focus in on the median to just explain the
particular example. Because as you can see,
there's an intricacy here associated with
the break up.
And so here we go. I'm going to draw out a
picture. And we're going to try and argue
that this deterministic strategy that I'll
specify gives you fairly balanced partitions
in all cases, OK?
So what we see here is we see-- pictorially,
you see columns of length five. Each of these
dots corresponds to a number. This one dimensional
array got turned into a two dimensional right.
So I got four full columns. And it's suddenly
possible, given n, that my fifth column is
not full, right? So that's certainly possible.
So that's why I have that up here. It so what
I've here is I'm going to lay them out this
way.
And I'm going to look at that. I'm going to
look at the middle elements of each of these
n over five columns. That's exactly what I'm
going to look at. Now, if I look at what I
want, what I want over here is this x. If
I want to find--
I'm going to find the median of medians. So
is x. Now, it is true the first that
these columns-- I'm just putting that up here
imagining that that's x.
That's not guaranteed to be x because the
columns themselves aren't-- well, these columns
are sorted. And what I'm going to have to
guarantee, of course, is that when I go find
this median of medians is that it ends up
being something that gives me balanced partitions.
So maybe say a little bit more before I explain
what's going on.
Each of these columns is sorted. And s is
arranged into columns of size 5 like I just
said here. These are the medians, OK? If I
look at determining the medians and I say
that once I've determined this x, which I've
discovered that it's the median, then this
is right there in the middle. There's going
to be a bunch of columns to the left of it,
a bunch of elements to the left of it, and
a bunch of elements to the right of it.
And in this case, I have five columns. I could
have had more. It happens to be the third
one.
So the idea is that once I find this median
of medians, which corresponds to this x number,
I can say that all of the columns-- these
all correspond to columns that have their
median element greater than x. These correspond
to columns that have their median element
less than x, OK? So what I have here in this
picture is that these elements here are going
to be greater than x.
And these elements here are going to be less
than x. So let me clear. What's happened here
is we've not only sorted all of the columns
such that you have large elements up here.
Each of these five columns have been sorted
that way. On top of that, I've discovered
the particular column that corresponds to
the medians of medians. And this is my x over
here.
And it may be the case that these columns
aren't sorted. This one may be larger than
that or vice versa-- same thing over there.
I have no idea.
But it's guaranteed that once I find this
median that I do know all of the columns that
have elements in this position that are less
than this x. And I know columns that in this
position have elements that are greater than
x, OK? Yep.
STUDENT: Shouldn't the two elements below x also be computed [INAUDIBLE] less than x.
PROFESSOR: You're exactly right. I would have
probably been able to get the same asymptotic
complexity if I dropped those because I had
a constant number. But you're absolutely exactly
right.
So the point that-- the question was-- I just
redrew it. These two are clearly less than
x as well because they're part of the sorting.
And that's essentially I have here.
Now, my goal here-- and you can kind of see
from here as to where we're headed. What I've
down here by this process of sorting each
column and finding the median of medians is
that I found this median of medians such that
there's a bunch of columns on the left. And
roughly half of those elements in those columns
are less than x.
And there are a bunch of columns on the right.
And roughly half of those columns have elements
that are greater than x. So what I now have
to do is to do a little bit of math to show
you exactly what the recurrence is. And let
me do that over here.
So that's the last thing that we have to do.
I probably won't solve the recurrence, but
that can wait until tomorrow. The recurrence
will be something that's not particularly
difficult to solve. So I want to now make
a more quantitative argument that the variable
being n as to how many elements are guaranteed
to be greater than x.
And essentially what I'm saying, which is
I'm writing out what I have on that picture
there, half of the n over 5 groups contribute
at least three elements greater than x except
for one group with possibly less than five
elements, which is the one that I have all
the way to the right, and one group that contains
x.
So for all the other columns, I'm going to
get three elements that are greater than x.
And so if you write that out, this says there
are at least three n over 10, because I have
half of all of those groups, minus 2.
And I'm not counting perfectly accurately
here, but I have an at least. So this should
all be fine. 3n over 1d-- 3 times n over 10
minus 2 elements are strictly greater than
x. And that comes from that picture.
I'm going to be able to say the same thing
for less than x as well. I can't count the
one. Depending on how things go, maybe I could
have played around and subtracted 1 instead
of a 2 in the latter case.
But I'm just being conservative here. It is
clear that I'm going to have a bunch of columns
that are full columns, that are going to be
contributing three elements that are greater
than x. And in this case, I have, well, two
of them here for the less than x.
And I got one for the greater than x. So that's
all that I'm seeing over here with respect
to the balance of the partitions. And it turns
out that's enough.
It turns out all I have to do with this observation
is to go off and run the recurrence. And we're
going to get an efficient algorithm. Yep.
STUDENT: Should it not be like greater than or equal to, because there's... [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: No, there's nothing that's equal.
STUDENT: So you are saying, that's all you need.
PROFESSOR: Yeah. Yeah, I assume that-- so,
convenience, yeah. There's always a little
bit of convenience thrown in here.
We will assume that the a has unique elements.
So there's nothing that's x, OK? Good.
So the recurrence, once you do that, is t
of n equals-- we're going to just say it's
order one for n less than or equal to 140.
Where did that come from? Well, like 140.
It's just a large number. It came from the
fact that you're going to see 10 minus 3,
which is 7. And then you want to multiply
that by 2.
So some reasonably large number-- we're going
to go off and we're going to assume that's
a constant. So you could sort those 140 numbers
and find the median or whatever rank. It's
all constant time once you get down to the
base case.
So you just want it to be large enough such
that you could break it up and you have something
interesting going on with respect to the number
of columns. So don't worry much about that
number. The key thing here is the recurrence,
all right?
And this is what we have spent the rest of
our time on. And I'll just write this out
and explain where these numbers came from.
So that's our recurrence for n less than or
equal to 140.
And else, you're going to do this. So what
is going on here? What are all of these components
corresponding to this recurrence?
Really quickly, this is simply something that
says I'm finding the median of medians. I'm
finding some element that has a certain rank.
So this median of medians is going to be running
on n over 5 columns. So I've got this-- there
are n over 5 columns here.
And I'm going to be calling this algorithm
recursively, the median finding algorithm,
to do that-- finding the median of medians.
This thing over here is-- I'm going to be
discarding at least regardless of what I do.
Because I have these two statements here,
I take the overall n. And I'm going to discard.
In my paradigm over here, I'm either going
to go with b or I'm either going to go with
c depending on what I'm looking for. And given
that b and c are not completely unbalanced,
I'm going to be discarding 3n over 10 minus
6 elements, which simply corresponds to me
ignoring the ceiling here and multiplying
the 3 out. So that's 3n over 10 minus 6.
So then I have 7n over 10 plus 6. That's the
maximum size partition that I'm going to recur
on. It's only going to be exactly one of them,
as you can see from that.
It's either else. It's not recurring on both
of them. It's recurring on one of them. So
that's where the 7n over 10 plus 6 comes from.
And then you ask where does this theta n come
from.
Well, the theta n comes from the fact that
I do have to do some sorting. It's constant
time sorting for every column, OK? Because
it's only five elements.
So I'm going to do constant time sorting.
But there's order n columns. Because it's--
then it's n over 5 columns.
So this is the sorting of all of the columns,
all right? So that's it. And I'll just leave
you with-- you cannot apply the master theorem
for solving this particular recurrence. But
if you make the observation-- and you'll see
this in section.
You make the observation that n over 5 plus
7n over 10 is actually less than n. So you
get 0.2n here and 0.7n there. That's actually
less than n.
This thing runs in linear time. And you'll
see that in section tomorrow. So this whole
thing is theta n time. See you next time.